I've never really been into jury as a
kid I'm just super into fashion in
general so I think you know when you
look good you feel good and Joey
definitely can add today I was handed
people
I'm Jason Derulo and this is GQ on the
rocks all right so I guess we can start
here this for represents my everything
is for album and the reason why I called
the album everything is for is because I
was seeing for everywhere you know and I
feel like for is like a complete number
four seasons it says a whole pie right
for his whole and I was just feeling
very thankful for my life and I felt
very full and I blessed with where I was
that in life this piece right here is an
AP and it's 2-tone I'm not usually a fan
of rose gold so this was like the first
rose gold piece that I bought and you
know it took me a second to buy but I
was just so in love with the
craftsmanship actually performed in
Saudi Arabia at the first concert in
history where women and men could be in
the audience at the same time and it was
the first time that's ever happened it
was like an emotional experience I mean
people were crying in the audience as
you could imagine as a crazy experience
for me as well just to be a part of that
history that legacy right after that
when I got to the to the house you know
I'm wanting something special and I
think this this is about peace is really
special someone of a kind and I hope
nobody else has it because they told me
isn't one of a gun while we're on
watches in a travel case like this one I
want to be sure that I have a watch for
every occasion you definitely want to
make sure you have your Platinum's you
want to have your goals and you want to
have the two tones where you can wear
other jewelry with it so you know
talking about my rings I want to wear
all gold rings I could easily throw on
you know a gold watch that has a few
timings in it and being and be slick if
I was gonna be a little toned down I
brought this one you know I'm saying if
I got a turtleneck on you know and I'm
gonna do is something super classy I got
some boobs I probably won't wear any
diamonds at all just kind of keep it
super classy it's very tamed but for the
bus down on occasions I like to I like
to rock this one this is like a bus down
occasion basically in any lighting you
know you're gonna hook up the whole room
you know I'm saying it's a chandelier
like calaboose a chandelier this is an
AP as well I've grown to love a piece
over the years a custom ap easily can go
for about $150,000 you know it just kind
of depends on on the craftsmanship
that's something that I really pay
attention to the setting of the Diamonds
because it matters you know in the shine
it matters and you know how it how it
kind of comes across but you know I've
just become a watch collector over the
years so I'm you know I pay attention in
that kind of [ __ ] so this piece right
here this is significant because this is
not my ring at all actually bought this
from my ex-girlfriend it's not a
situation where like she's like [ __ ]
Julie is your ring there was not that
kind of breakup at all you know it has
has a B on the front I remember in
within my bedroom there was a beehive
like right outside my room so the bees
were kind of sneaking in my room somehow
and I had I was just infested with bees
in my bedroom it was the crazy [ __ ] you
could imagine if that experience you
know kind of kind of rang very true so
like I bought our ring that had it be
honest you know I think I'll just give
it back to her
so when I'm packing for tour I think
about what I'm gonna wear for my show
and usually what I'm wearing for my show
chain wise will be choker like this I
don't even know if you call it so
children has immunity is kind of choking
me but it's not like super tight because
it's it fits close to my body that can't
be flopping around because I move and
dance a lot and sometimes you know you
can get whacked in the face with my
black thing almost like it ends up crazy
like the other day I had a long gold
chain on as my I had a goldfish so I was
like yeah this chain looks crazy and I
did a flip back in and of course the
chain went above my head and it got
stuck in my in my in your's so I had to
take off my in ears and then take off
the chain it's during the show and I
actually don't wear rings on stage
because I lose I'm 100 percent of the
time this one is it's this is probably
like my favorite chain ever the size the
third thing the fact that is black is is
pretty crazy so these are both Rafael
Rafael encode I believe this one was
90,000 yeah I do yeah
I'm into the the hanging pieces have
been for bother I think three years now
I've been to the hanging earrings
fashion is recycled and it's deciding
when to bring certain things back and I
thought it was Tom definitely for
bringing her back and it's been it's
been fun to see everybody follow suit so
this was my first rose gold chain that I
bought it meanness makes obviously with
platinum and rose gold
I bought this purely to match her the
rose gold and platinum watch this this
is a set to match but I call this the
black panther joint because when I
whenever I put this on I feel very I
feel very ethnic and I feel very rooted
to my roots in hymns in this I believe
this one was about
sixty thousand you've never seen a chain
like this this is this is a
one-of-a-kind this was special made this
chain right here this was given to me by
my cousin everybody around me knows that
if you got something on and I'll [ __ ]
with it then chances are you know I'm
gonna have to like like wear it somehow
you know say whether it's like a belt or
some shoes if I like what you got on
better than what I got on
Oh nah bro come on so this J is for
Johnny like that yo let me wear that
everywhere that once off and it's never
left my bleep in my briefcase so I
actually gave him a Rolex and returned
which the Rolex was a lot more expensive
but uh yeah he did me a solid so I
didn't solid so this is a one-of-a-kind
piece as well man I mean this one is
annoying as [ __ ] to be honest I hardly
ever wear this one I really like it it's
was custom made it was like something
that I should give to my dog so I
actually tried to try it around my dog's
neck and it wouldn't fit around his neck
because his [ __ ] super fat uh-huh it
has like this vibe that I want but the
[ __ ] just always get tangled like like
my brother and the only person that can
fix it is my brother like I'm like Joe
can you face this shipment so I hardly
ever wear it this is probably 40 40 50
Oh so this piece right here was actually
given to me on my birthday just recently
I was given to me by a friend in Dubai
we share the same birthday and yeah he
just you know popped up and gave me a
bracelet and I thought it was really
cool I don't normally wear too many
bridges but yeah I think I think it's
about wearing all the time now so this
is platinum and there are there are
diamonds
it's a diamond-encrusted you know it's
not too much it's not like super daddy
is very classy I feel like you can rock
this and in any instant you know
so the special thing about this chain
here is that every single side is
encrusted endowment so look at this like
every piece you know so it just makes it
shine a lot more than that there's chain
because the the diamonds are are really
small and spread across every single in
every single area remember how much this
was to be honest but I remember him
saying it know this will cost that much
because look at the setting look at the
setting that's the [ __ ] that they always
give you look look at the setting look
how its set bro my god I have a really
good knowledge when it comes to jewelry
especially because I shop around you
know I don't necessarily just go off
with one person's price you know if if I
seen this chain and I like it I'll go to
two other jewelers and I'll see what
they have what they'll give it to me for
but I also check you know how how the
the diamonds are set in the
craftsmanship on the piece just so that
you know you you're comparing apples to
apples right just because a piece is
cheaper on this side doesn't necessarily
mean it's better yeah so this one is a
super fob as well this one I'd like to
wear often oh and that the rose gold
piece you could sell out like that watch
now this one has a class and the class
for dope because just gives you that
extra bit of a bust down you know and
just so you know the style is to wear
the bus down portion on the side so mine
are in the back right now so this is
wrong so you kind of want it like right
on the side so he kind of shows a bit
you don't want all the way in the back
cuz nobody sees the back that you can
also do in the wrong way in the front
cuz you know then it'll look like too
showy is like look at it look at the
diamonds so you kind of wet it like
right on the side so it's kind of like
a little bit this one was about 14 as
well my mom actually made this my
mother's in Miami once you spend a
million dollars with the high mob he
gives you one of these cases and this
the case on you a lot to you like just
like my favorite it's like my favorite
case is that Gator skin what is that
ostrich ostrich ostrich skiff um this is
a cool chain these are actually not
diamonds at all so this is cool because
these these platinum platinum balls
pause they're cut in a way where they
shine they shine really well and they
kind of look like diamonds you know so
it has it has a shine to it without you
know having to break the bank at all
which i think is cool you know it's like
like right in the middle it's a classy
Bob these are pretty pretty simple it's
just you know a regular diamond change
the charm is cool so the charm has a
bunch of little diamonds kinda here kind
of reminds you of a kids game but I'm
kidding about this it's a diamond chain
it probably runs
maybe 70,000 like this in the charm the
charm is probably not as much as
probably maybe like 15,000 or something
like that I really like this piece I'll
wear this on special occasions I feel
like this piece is like ultimate piece
of class you know I'll put that on I'm
saying feel special feel special you
know you can make anybody feel special
with this chain you wanna make somebody
feel special you put this piece together
you know I'm really thoughtful when it
comes to money for a long period of time
I only bought gold so like I just had
gold gold gold everything because you
know you can't lose with gold but
eventually it was like man you can't
treat every single thing in life as it
as an investment now I try to enjoy
myself and just do things you know that
just made me happy